it wasn't a plan to open up american
business
or american schools president obama
announced that it was his priority to
offer citizenship for 11 million
undocumented immigrants
what did he think would happen just last
month alone
a hundred thousand migrants were
encountered
encountered attempting to illegally
cross our border
put that in perspective a hundred
thousand
that's a larger population than
president biden's hometown of scranton
pennsylvania
the number of migrant children detained
at the border had tripled in two weeks
they're in jail-like sales the number of
migrants who have tested positive
for coronavirus after being released by
the border control
in texas has nearly doubled
as republicans we know how to solve this
problem we could work with
administrations to make it happen
last week i sent a letter to the
president asking to sit down with him
to work on ideas to reverse some of the
misuse
and misdirected policies that he had
attempted at the beginning in creating
this policy
creating this crisis as of today he
still has not answered our letter
to attempt to meet next week we'll be
traveling to the border myself with the
12 other members to see firsthand to
come back with solutions
to make sure our border is secure but to
make sure we can end
this crisis that biden has created with
that
i want to introduce our republican whip
steve scalise
[Applause]
thank you kevin we're very concerned
about this crisis
at the border that has been created
specifically by joe biden's policies
president biden's border crisis has got
to get reversed
if you look at where we are right now
you have thousands of people
crossing illegally into the united
states every single day
those border states are getting overrun
it's a drain on their resources
they're super spreader caravans coming
across
and this was all done by president biden
and president biden can
address and reverse this policy we're
calling on president biden
to reverse his policy that's created
this biden border crisis
it's not very complicated when you look
at what president trump had done the
remain in mexico policy
was an example of a president working
with our neighbor
in this case mexico to solve a problem
that not only existed at america's
border
but it's created a new problem at
mexico's southern border because many of
the people coming across these
caravans are coming through central and
south american countries
through mexico and so the original
policy
to remain in mexico while asylum cases
for example would be worked out
was a much more humane process and in
fact reduce
what we're seeing right now in these
caravans you have young women
who are being exploited the human
trafficking is getting out of control
and the abuse of these women should be a
major concern
again this is something that president
biden created and he can fix this today
by reversing the order he's got to
recognize the policy failed
any good leader would look in the mirror
and if they made a mistake they would
acknowledge this as a mistake
and they would fix it because he himself
can fix this right now
first step though is to admit that there
is a crisis it seems like the white
house right now is in denial
about the crisis right as it is stands
president biden himself won't even go to
the border
he sent a group of people down he
wouldn't even meet with them for days
because i think he wants to ignore this
problem
the problem's getting worse it's getting
worse and it's dramatically affecting
other states
when you think about the fact that right
now president biden is implementing
policies that are keeping schools closed
yet he send a message around south and
central america that our border is open
that's the wrong message strong message
for america
and it's doing a disservice to those
people in those caravans who are being
abused every single day
it's got to stop president biden created
this problem president biden needs to
fix
this problem but that'll bring up our
conference chair liz cheney
thanks very much whip and thanks leader
um you know we have to recognize that
words have consequences
and actions have consequences when the
byte administration refuses to enforce
our immigration laws
when they refuse to build the wall when
they pass legislation like the bill that
we passed yesterday that includes
money uh for illegal immigrants uh this
is what happens
what happens and what's going on right
now at the border is foreseeable
foreseeable consequence of their
statements of their policies
they caused this they are responsible
and speaker pelosi is compounding the
issue and she is compounding the danger
to the american people
simultaneously we are seeing the bite
administration open borders
we are seeing the democrats in the house
under speaker pelosi move to defund the
police
move to infringe on the gun rights of
law-abiding citizens
all of this combines to form a very
dangerous
and toxic mix and when you are
the president of the united states when
you are sitting in the white house
it's not enough to express concern about
the challenge it's not enough to ignore
the challenge it's uh an abdication of
your responsibility if you ignore the
challenge
so we're calling on the biden
administration to take action
immediately to secure the border to stop
what we're seeing happen
to change the policies to make clear
that the hundreds of thousands of people
that we've seen now
attempting to enter the country
illegally uh will not
be able to do so uh they need to
reiterate
and recommit to protecting and securing
the nation into protecting the american
people
and with that i will yield to the
republican leader of the homeland
security committee mr catco
thank you everybody what we are
witnessing of course is a biden's border
crisis
if you want to think of it another way
it's disorder at the border
by executive order to channel dr seuss
disorder by executive order i can say it
five times fast
president biden's knee-jerk reversal of
productive and effective
border security policies from the
previous administration
was a political calculation that has
created humanitarian
security and public health crisis
instead of being transparent with
congress
and the american people about what is
happening at the border the
administration is twisting itself into a
pretzel
to avoid saying the dreaded word crisis
all we heard at the white house
yesterday was a refusal to take
responsibility
and yet to be revealed long-term
objectives that's not an answer to this
crisis
we are a nation of laws but instead of
enforcing the law here's what the
administration is chosen to do
help halt border wall construction in
its tracks
re-implement the dr the dreadful catch
and release program policies allowing
migrants
to flow in the united states raise up
their hands say the magic word asylum
approaching the united states
once they know that's acceptable they're
going to be coming in droves and we
already see that with the facts
they've eliminated the critical
remaining mexico policy which is humane
and is working
and it canceled the asylum cooperative
agreements with our central american
partners
that's what they've done what they
haven't done is admit that it's caused a
crisis
and the facts speak for themselves let
me just give you a couple of facts
last month cbp encountered over 100 000
individuals
seeking to cross a southwest border
that's a 28 increase in just one month
and 173 percent higher than the same
time
just one year ago another fact for you
cbp currently counters an average of
more than 3 000 individuals a day
when jay johnson was secretary of
homeland security he said
a thousand individuals coming across the
border a day is quote a bad
day end quote another fact hundreds of
border patrol agents are being diverted
from interior drug checkpoints
in the northern coastal borders to rio
grande valley the administration is even
asking for people to volunteer to come
to the border to help with the
i can't say the word but it is it's a
crisis
international travel you can't come from
england by plane
if you fly from mexico by plane you
first have to have a test to show your
coventry
yet you can walk across the border and
come right in what is wrong with us what
are we doing
right the high volume of the
unaccompanied children
encountered at the border continues to
rise reports indicate
cbp is projecting 13 000 unaccompanied
children crossing the border per month
by may and health and human services
facilities
are reaching capacity so what are they
doing they're checking with nasa
and the department of defense to find
warehouses to put all these accompany
unaccompanied children are coming across
the border because biden puts
come on inside on the border that is
that is
not right all of this was project
predictable
these politically motivated policies
have created a crisis that must be
reversed
i'll stop at what i said at the
beginning there's disorder at the border
because of his executive order
and let me introduce next speaker at
cage ranger
i've been to the border many times as
the head of the 2014
task force created to address the
alarming number of unaccompanied
children coming border
i've seen firsthand what a border crisis
looks like
so believe me when i say we're once
again facing a crisis on our southern
border
not only has the biden administration
repeatedly failed to recognize the
crisis
even exist they've stopped construction
at the border
wall virtually eliminated enforcement of
immigration laws and reverse trump
administration policies that were so
successful
in decreasing illegal crossings over the
last few years
just last week the secretary of homeland
security
had a troubling and confusing message to
those seeking to cross our border
illegally
he said we're not saying don't come
we're saying
don't come now this will only encourage
more illegal crossings at the southern
border from those expecting easy access
uh to our nation overwhelming law
enforcement and increasing the potential
for human trafficking child labor and
other criminal
criminal and fraudulent activity in
border cities across the southwest
we can't ignore the problem and hope it
goes away
instead of addressing this crisis
speaker pelosi has spent the last few
weeks focused on a
trillion dollar payout to progressives i
urge the speaker and the biden
administration
to get their heads out of the sand and
work with us to address his crisis
immediately
jody arrington west texas
i want to thank our ranking member john
rhyme no rhythm catco
the american people are well served to
have this man at the helm
he is a former prosecutor he understands
what rule of law means to our great
nation and what happens
when you don't enforce the laws you get
chaos
and as a text and i'm telling you our
people are crying out for help they're
struggling
they're scared and they're not getting
any response
any leadership out of this president
and uh we are on the front lines in
texas and border states
our people your fellow americans
uh are are at ground zero in this
unmitigated disaster this is a
self-inflicted crisis
as a direct result of the biden
administration
policies the unilateral actions the
deluge
of executive orders as has been said
reinstating catch and release
rescinding border wall funding and stay
in mexico policies just to name
a few policies have consequences you
show me a policy
and i'll show you the outcome and the
outcome
of these policies have wreaked havoc
along the border and in border
communities double the apprehensions
in january cbp reported just yesterday
over a hundred thousand apprehensions
illegal crossings that we cut
in the month of february triple the
number of migrant children
being trafficked across the border
by cartels their pawns ladies and
gentlemen
these cartels prey on these vulnerable
people
and the abuses are atrocious
one in every three women are sexually
assaulted
it's a humanitarian crisis of epic
proportion
the message from this president who
fails to call it a crisis because he has
the worst case of
suspended reality i've ever seen
the message is clear the safety and
security of the american people is not
his top priority
and the message to people who would come
to our country
and violate our laws and our sovereignty
and jeopardize the safety
and security of the american people will
not be
detained and deported they will be
released
and rewarded free health care
free education compliments of the
taxpayers of the united states
and oh by the way with this latest
democrat bill they'll get a pathway to
citizenship and we wonder why
the border is burning last question
the most important question for all of
you to ask the president
and i know it's the question on the
hearts and minds of the american people
why is it happening why is the president
allowing this to happen
well i i believe it's because number one
he's obsessed with undoing everything
every policy that has the name donald
trump on it
regardless of the merits of that policy
he's equally obsessed
with acquiescing to every demand of the
radical left
i yield back
good morning i'm debbie lesko
congressman from
great border state of arizona
and i'm here to tell you right from the
mouse of arizona law enforcement
officers
that there is a crisis at the southern
border
and the reason that i know that is
because the yuma
mayor the yuma arizona sheriff
the cochise county arizona sheriff
have said that mass amounts of illegal
immigrants are flooding over the border
ice facilities are overcrowded
thousands of unaccompanied children
many of them not even tested for covid
are being
released into their communities
they have reached out to the biden
administration
our arizona attorney general
who joined the lawsuit that has been
the court has held up has adjusted his
lawsuit
just yesterday because of the biden
policies
on ice and quote this is from attorney
general brnovich from arizona
if asked about the poorest policy choice
i've ever seen in government
this would be a strong contender
blindly releasing thousands of people
including convicted criminals and those
who may be spreading covet 19
into our state is both unconscionable
and a violation of federal law
this must be stopped now to avoid
a dangerous humanitarian crisis for the
immigrants
and the people of arizona last time i
went down to yuma arizona
the yuma arizona sheriff showed me a
date tree
farm where he has been called he and his
officers
multiple times because immigrant women
and girls are being raped
they're being raped by the cartels who
don't give a damn about these people
all they care about the money so the
biden's policies are incentivizing this
they're incentivizing these poor people
to flood across our border travel
thousands of miles at the hands of the
cartel
i would say the biden administration
is culpable child abuse
and abuse of these women and children
and it needs to be stopped
and with that i introduce the great
congressman
from texas tony gonzalez
[Applause]
america is beautiful and what makes us
beautiful
we are a nation of immigrants we are
also
a nation of laws border security
and legal immigration go hand in hand
my district is over 800 miles of texas
and mexico border
i'm on the border every single week and
what i've seen
is this administration's open border
rhetoric
has caused a crisis and i urge this
administration
to listen to those that are on the
border democrats and republicans alike
listen to the crisis that has occurred
we're traveling to the border again
early next week
i urge the biden administration to take
hold
and focus on legal immigration
not illegal immigration with that i turn
it over to a vet hero
[Applause]
thank you thank you for being here just
a quick question to get it in
perspective i see most of you have some
kind of lanyard on your neck
did you have to go through any kind of
security to get here
i bet you did so you're going to go
through security to get into
the pelosi compound and yet people are
walking across the border
just freely it is a huge problem at the
border crisis
and i'll bet most of you have had to
have a covet test
before you could come in and do any kind
of coverage at the inauguration or
anything like that
guess what that's not happening at the
border and the reason we need to stand
in support of the paws act is because we
need the biden administration to keep
title 42 in place
so that we can protect the citizens of
our nation this has nothing to do with
politics the paws act is actually
about protecting the health and safety
of the american people
we're asking him let our border patrol
agents expel those coming into the
nation
illegally through mexico or canada on
the border
so that we can protect our seniors our
children our communities
it is not fair that we have been in a
mass
situation in lockdown close businesses
two thousand businesses in my state will
not recover because of coven 19.
loved ones are dying alone we're not
educating our kids
and yet we think it's a good idea to
somehow open the border and put
not only the american people but those
making that trek across the
the countries to get here in harm's way
it doesn't make sense
but what i can tell you is with the
biden border crisis
what this administration has done and
make no mistake
they have made the federal government
the last link in the chain
of human smuggling for these children so
let's do what is right for the people of
america
for change let's get our priorities set
because let's not forget who worked for
the people of america
not for the illegals and not just for
nancy pelosi and her policies
let's protect merkin first thank you
thank you
that that concludes uh the speeches man
i thank you all very much for coming and
just remember
get the administration to call it a
crisis because that's what it is thank
you very much everybody